[Musique]
approche assez rapidement c'est là on
est prévue le 20 avril
c'est un dans un petit peu moins de deux
mois et donc il faut finir vraiment tout
ce qui est système enfin se préparer la
station spatiale est sortie
extravéhiculaire et sur la fin on va
vraiment on va vraiment se concentrer
sur la capsule le voyage aller en fait
qu ils m'ont quand même le plus intense
un peu plus dangereux et on va dire gspc
il faut vraiment être prêt pour ça on va
voir nos scaphandre sur mesure qui vont
être faits bientôt on va pouvoir
commencer à s'entraîner avec eux ce
qu'on n'a pas fait pour l'instant
et puis on va commencer à devenir des
cobayes aussi pour les expériences
scientifiques qui vont reprendre
prélèvement d'un petit peu tout ce qu'on
peut imaginer pour
[Musique]
changement entraînements ce moment avec
la situation de tacots lui de situation
sanitaire
c'est qu'on a avec moi à se découvrir
parce qu'en fait évidemment on travaille
ensemble toute la journée
mais là on se découvre est vraiment
c'était peut-être en dehors du travail
c'était quand on a fait faire des stages
de survie où c'était simplement en
allant dîner en s'invitant les gens
c'est chez les autres rencontres et les
familles et puis et puis c'est là que
quelque part on apprenait vraiment à se
connaître
combes briser la glace qu'on savait pas
ce qu'il faisait fonctionner l'ins qui
n'aimait pas ce que donc ça c'était
super utile après pour former une équipe
et puis pour fonctionner correctement à
bord de la station malheureusement toute
cette partie là on l'a plus est la
partie qui a été supprimée par le à la
situation sanitaire ont encore vraiment
la partie technique du travail mais
toute cette partie un peu personnel
psychologique formation de team building
comme on dit celle là elle a été un peu
supris mais 4 à 6 ans non je serais très
optimiste on va dire c'est peut-être un
bon argument de vente mais mais nous
c'est pas cet horizon là qu'on vise dans
les agences mais par contre oui 15 ans
avait 15 ans ça me paraît pas
raisonnable c'est pas c'est pas si
compliqué d'aller sur mars est juste
très très loin c'est ça notre problème
c'est pas d'une complexité folle
c'est malheureusement la station
spatiale 400 km d'altitude la lune c'est
384000 donc on va dire 400 milles c'est
mille fois plus loin et mars quand on
est haut plus loin c'est 400 millions
qui auraient donc cinquante mille fois
plus loin avec quand même un facteur 1
million entre mars et la station
spatiale ce qu'on a derrière la tête
c'est quand même la destination finale
qui est mars la manière dont je vois moi
c'est vraiment comme c'est une étape
aussi technique c'est on sait pas
traverser l'atlantique en avion on va
dire d'abord on va apprendre à traverser
la manche
ensuite on a traversé la méditerranée
puis une fois qu'on en a long à fait
simple on va se lancer